so yesterday yeah during the show I
think first hour yeah I I get a DM from
Albert and he's just like you personally
are from the show or what yeah me
personally yeah so it was like hey you
know I've tried to give rich his space I
bring him on here hold on a second he
said Albert briefly even I'm not that
mean Albert said okay Albert are you
were you just were you I guess spying I
don't I didn't want to be mean but I
didn't have a chance so I was on my feet
like I was on my feet for part of the
day and I was in the train for another
part of the day sure I would have
listened to you guys live but I was sort
of like doing stuff and so I just wanted
to catch your reaction and I didn't want
to like I don't know man like like at
this point it's just mean it's like
eight in a row and it's the second
straight year you know with the score in
the 50s and a double digit margin and I
just I just wanted to give you your
space I appreciate that but you were you
MOT so you were monitoring the show to
see your reaction is I want to hear you
I wanted to hear your take on horrible
that's what I wanted to hear but it's so
I figured you'd have some sort of take
on horrible which eventually I did like
Chris Chris said he posted I don't think
Chris Chris you didn't you didn't you
didn't come through for me there
so I eventually listened to it the
podcast and I did get here your your
take on Harbaugh but I I was just sort
of interested because you're like you
know you're a pretty reasonable guy I
was interested to see what a reasonable
guy who went to school then who's
passionate about where he went to school
about what his take would be on Harbaugh
post a second straight loss like that
hmm do you think Harbaugh is gonna get
NFL feelers like he has over the last
few years and what are you hearing about
that Albert I think you stay in Michigan
but I think he'll probably get some
feelers yeah and I think that's part of
that is because I think teams are going
to be a little bit more I would say a
little bit more open-minded about where
they look this year because everybody's
been fishing off the same pier for the
last couple of years everybody's been
looking for the young innovative
offensive mind and you know so I think
the team is that
that do have openings this year are
going to look a little bit more outside
the box that's good news for you no
defensive coordinator types guys like
you know Robert style out in San
Francisco Chris Rashard and Dallas
Dennis Allen in New Orleans Matty broke
loose and Indianapolis it's good news
too I think for some of the college
coaches even if they aren't planning on
taking those jobs because you know as
well as I do those can lead to raises
you're gonna hear names like you know
like Matt rule from Baylor like Lincoln
Riley from Oklahoma like Urban Meyer
you've already heard his name some and
you know obviously once teams start
looking around the college ranks Jim
Harbaugh is just a natural call to make
because he's been to a Super Bowl before
well I mean we heard Jerry Jones today
Albert basically say that
Garrett still has the opportunity to
make a run and checkboxes not hit a
raise a bar that the bar is not raised
he knows where the bar is he just needs
to check boxes but that Jason Garrett's
in his mind is is absolutely capable of
doing the job to the point where he said
that Jason Garrett will be coaching in
the NFL next year and just left and I
yeah and I think that to me I think that
Jade that Jerry's criticism of Jason is
it's very interested to timing of it
like when it got when it sort of got a
little edgier the timing of it's
interesting because it was it coincided
was reporting coming out and I believe
it was on your air I think it was he in
right on Garrett potentially landing
with the Giants and I don't know that I
put this way I don't think that that
rubbed Jerry the right way that you know
they're all in on this season and
everything else and there's something
like that would sort of emerge I think
may have rubbed Jerry the wrong way and
contributed to you know what he said in
addition to everything that happened in
the New England game in his decision to
get a little bit edgier with his
criticism and I think an important piece
of this too rich when we're talking
about where the bar is and what Jason
Garrett needs to do to keep his job in
Dallas he doesn't have a contract for
next year and that's pretty rare like
you do not often see teams and coaches
into a lame-duck year now the Cowboys
have done it before with Jason it's not
the four
time but what it basically means is you
can walk away from the from the from the
coach with no financial repercussions
right but if you're planning on keeping
him then you've got to put together a
whole new contract of four or five years
for the guy and that means committing
you know in most cases 3040 million
dollars to to the coach that you've had
in your building for the last few years
and so that's where I think the bar is
high for Jason now too
he's gonna have to clear bar that's
gonna convince the Jones family to go
back in on him at that level and that's
why I think it's going to take more than
just making the play with the NFC East
being as down as it is for him to for
him to remain there in charge of the
Cowboys and if and if he's not in charge
of the Cowboys like Ian said a couple
weeks ago I would expect that the Giants
would kick the tires on them if they
make a change
Alber brewer here on the Rich Eisen show
let me just push back on that one I just
didn't think Giants fans after what's
happened you know to go from McAdoo to
Shermer to go to the guy that that
couldn't get it done for the Dallas
Cowboys much to the delight of the
Giants fan base for the last ten years
to for them to turn around say this is
the guy would be a very difficult sell
in the New York City area
despite Garrett's excellence as a human
being as well as the X's and O's and
being a former giant Princeton guy and
Jersey connections I that would be a
tough sell to me Albert did really well
I'll give you I'll give you two pieces
of information there okay number one
this is this is sort of part and parcel
to who to who John Mayer has been as the
owner who the mayor family has been as
owner some that they value familiarity
it's one of the reasons why Dave
gentlemen wound up you know getting the
job as GM it's why they hired Jerry
reasons why they brought Tom Coughlin's
back you know after they fired I believe
it was fossil right all those years ago
so they value familiarity they've got
familiarity with jason garrett here's
the other piece i know of a couple of
coaches who've left New York and gone to
Dallas over the last few years where
when they had their exit interview with
with with the Maris
basically the message on the way out the
door was we hate to lose you but if
there's one place if there's one person
that you're gonna go work for we don't
mind that that person is Jason Garrett
so the mayor's think very very highly of
Jason Garrett and they've been not
public about it but I mean like to be
willing to say those that sort of thing
to outgoing coach is I mean you risk it
getting out there right and so you know
I do think that there's an affection for
the Garrett family they're from the
MERIS and for Jason Garrett in
particular they have familiarity with
them and that's why it works that said I
don't think Jason Garrett will be at the
top of their list I think right now
we'll say we're gonna make a change
I think Matt rule from Baylor would
probably be the guy at the top the list
will not be amazing because that's what
I know who was on the Jets list and they
decided to go with gates because they
thought the rule was too green and long
with the rest of his coaching staff
Albert Bree are here on the Rich Eisen
show but let's let's let's be honest
here if you are an owner of a team that
has say dak and you've got to give him
40 million a year or close to it or
you're the owner of a team that's got
say Baker Mayfield and you're the owner
of a team of say darn 'old who you're
gonna have to make a decision on do I
give him a golf or a Wentz contract
coming up in the next couple years or
even let's go down the list here Dwayne
Haskins gardner minshew drew Locke I
mean these are just names why wouldn't
you just throw yourself at Lincoln
Reilly and say let's roll and given an
absurd amount of money to that guy
Albert I think I think some teams are
going to and and I know he got feelers
last year I think that this is more like
what you're talking about I think it's
more about what Lincoln wants to do and
what NFL teams want to do because I I
can tell you that you know over the
course of the last two off seasons if
all 32 teams haven't been through there
to watch tape with Lincoln Reilly I
would tell you that the number is at
least at 29 or 30 almost every team is
sent either a front office person or a
coach through there to watch tape with
him to see what he does
learn from him and that's a pretty
powerful statement from the NFL as far
as what they think of Lincoln Riley is
an offensive mind but Lincoln Riley you
got to remember has a job where the
money is basically equal to what he be
making in most NFL jobs living in a
place with the cost of living isn't
outrageous and he's got all kinds of job
security and so I think there are a lot
of people in football who would argue
that Oklahoma that job right there is
Lincoln Riley has it right now might be
a top-15 job in the sport you know NFL
teams included and so you're gonna have
to convince Lincoln Riley to leave
Norman and that's you know I think gonna
be a difficult thing to do now that said
he's a Texan you grew up in Staten
Island right rich yes sir how hard would
it be to tell a kid from Staten Island
how hard would it be for a kid from
Staten Island to say no to managing the
Yankees that's it I mean that's right
that's what it is right like so like for
Lincoln Riley being a Texan and having
grown up there and not knowing how often
the Dallas Cowboys job is gonna come
open if they come to you then you know I
think it's very very difficult to say no
and you've got an established
relationship with the Jones family
Lincoln Lincoln recruited recruited John
Steven Steven Jones's son to be a
walk-on in Oklahoma that didn't work out
you know John Steven wound up at
Arkansas
but Steven did watch sit down and watch
tape with Lincoln Riley and the Jones
family things very very highly of
Lincoln Riley they see him as an
offensive savant as most NFL people do
and so you know I do think that Lincoln
Riley would be at or near the top of
their list if they make a change in
January and that's the one job where you
know III look at like a Riley and I say
to myself if I'm him that's probably a
really really really difficult one to
say no to what about urban to the
Cleveland Browns is that a pipe dream
for all the Ohio fans out there Albert
what about that
I don't think garbage III don't think
urban is gonna go to a place C and maybe
it's a hard string thing for him
I think one of the reasons why her band
wouldn't take a job outside of a
blueblood job in college is that
thinking could I just don't think he'd
want to go through a rebuild and I don't
know that he can handle it you know I
mean we've seen what one or two losses
did to him a year at Ohio State you know
we saw what losing a game or two a year
would do to him at Florida you know I
just think that there's if I think
there's you know I think Urban's have a
mind to listen and we'll listen if NFL
teams call I think if he's going to go
back at the college level it's going to
have to be in a place where he feels
like he can go 11 and 1 or 10 into every
single year and compete for national
championships every single year and if
he goes to an NFL an NFL team I think
it's gonna have to have two things I
think one it's gonna have to be he's
gonna have to be a flagship franchise
and number two I think it's gonna have
to be again a place where he thinks he
can win quickly and when consistently
and so I don't I don't know whether or
not he's done coaching but I do think
but but but i but I can tell you that my
belief is that he'll listen if NFL teams
call and it's going to have to be the
absolute right type of place which I
would tell you right now I think Dallas
would be more of a possibility for him
than Cleveland but what about the
opinion or the possibility of having on
your resume I took Ohio State and put
them on a pedestal with the rest of the
top elite programs in college football
and I turn I mean you can't say turned
it around and then do the same thing for
Cleveland for the Browns Albert I mean
hmm
go for it Paul Brown yeah right that's
what you're talking about
yes right that that took the Cleveland
Browns to where they needed to go and
then created the Bengals right I mean
it's your small brown want a national
championship at Ohio State right and
then went to Cleveland and created the
Browns and turned them into a powerhouse
yeah yeah I guess from that standpoint
it makes some sense I I like I said look
I know how our about I I know how ty
Durban is to the state and maybe again
it would be a hard string thing and
obviously he Kiko
against Bakker may feel twice in college
so he knows what Baker may feel this is
a player and maybe he feels like he when
there quickly I just I think if he had
any doubt about the infrastructure of a
place then I don't think he would do it
and my question would be whether or not
the Cleveland Browns who are a brand
name NFL franchise right my question
will be whether or not the Cleveland
Browns could convince him that the
infrastructure was in place where he
could win consistently and so what about
the Browns job in general based on them
being five and seven the whole t-shirt
business the crown of the helmet
nonsense the craziness and that has by
the way if I told you prior to the
season there five and seven and the
craziest thing that Adele would be part
of him wearing a watch during a game
right it's not it's not Odell the
question is what's wrong with the Browns
and what happened in these kitchens the
guy where do you where do you know where
does your reporting stand on that
subject my feeling right now would be
that they are more likely to make to
shuffle the staff than they are to make
a change with the head coach because
John Dorsey was all in on this guy then
John Dorsey I don't think John Dorsey
thought that Freddy was going to be a
finished product in 2019 and I think
that he knows that Freddy's failure is
his failure like everyone in the NFL
ties Freddy to him because he's the one
who stuck his neck out neck out and took
a swing on the guy and so you know I
again this is barring like things just
come coming completely undone over the
next month I think the likelihood would
be that Freddy would be back and there
would be some structural changes to the
staff and I think one thing that could
be on the table Todd Monken their
offensive coordinator who's really well
thought of I think it would be on the
table potentially that maybe Todd Monken
wants up being the play caller in 2020
and maybe Freddy becomes more of a kind
of a walk around type of head coach a
last one for you here Albert what's the
scuttlebutt on the draft is we're
sitting here right now it's a chase
young Joe burrow scenario or it is to or
is to are still lingering there with
everybody thinking he'll be nice and
healthy by March what what do you got
for me on that front yeah you know and I
think most of the teams that are looking
at quarterbacks are sort of looking at
the two-year outlay here
and I think you know that where that
takes us it takes us to Trevor Lawrence
in 2021 and you may remember in 2017 the
Browns and the Jets did it that way and
they wind up passing on the tour Biscay
watts and Holmes class and you know the
Jets wind up with darn 'old and the
Browns wind up with Mayfield the next
year I certainly think there's gonna be
some teams that are going to look at it
this way that way this year because the
quarterback class has high end potential
but there are certainly questions with
Jill burrow it's you know well he's only
done it at this level for one year with
with Justin Herbert it's well you know
guys super talented but he's still
really really raw and that's even after
playing a lot of football with two of
there's obviously the injury stuff and
so I think all three of those guys have
like first-round talent the question
they're questions surrounding each one
of them and that's where I think you
know a team could decide yeah maybe
we'll take chase young number one and
we'll look forward towards 2021 when
Trevor Lawrence is available and when
Justin fields could play his way into
being a high first-round pick as well
did I do well here Albert I took the
lumps like did you like how I suggest
and feels named in there at the end
no I didn't quite honestly I mean if you
wanna ask me straight phone question
about like this like I choose this look
the kid is great man and your team is
just on fire and I look forward to
seeing what that I guess it'll be them
against whoever sneaks in at 4:00 right
that'll be it we'll see I mean I I'm
still not convinced that the I think we
both know there's a very SEC frenzy just
means more our committee it just means
more right the SEC so so I don't think
it would shock anyone with who went to
school and the region of the country
that you and I went to school in if
suddenly LSU winds up number one in the
next week or two I don't know I just
think they want to avoid Ohio State
playing Clemson because we all know what
happened the last time that happened in
the college football you don't like how
I got the time
take care of yourself I forgot me that I
don't have a response chat soon that's
Albert brie or the mmq for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on VR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app